let's pull up the first story and this
is the one that actually kind of freaks
me out
from timcast.com written house jury was
recorded outside of the courthouse trial
judge says
wisconsin judge bruce schroeder
announced that someone had recorded the
jury in kyle rittenhouse's trial getting
off the bus this morning the identities
of the 18 members of the jury have been
sealed and kept anonymous during the
trial on the morning of november 9th
someone was observed recording the group
before they arrived by
arrived by bus quote at pickup there was
someone there and video recording the
jury which officers approached the
person and required them to delete the
video and return the phone to him
schroeder said i've instructed that if
it happens again they are to take the
phone and bring it here something like
that should not have occurred i'm
frankly quite surprised it didn't the
news comes shortly after cortes rice
george floyd's nephew said in a live
stream that he knew there were cameras
in the courtroom and that they were
quote definitely people taking pictures
of the jury and everything jury
selection was difficult because the case
extensive media coverage at least 12
potential jurors were dismissed because
they acknowledged they had strong
feelings about the case by november 2nd
20 people had been selected including 9
men and 11 women of the selected group
12 would serve as jurors while 8 were
alternates safety concerns were
expressed by jury members during the
selection process and mentioned fears of
riots following the verdict one juror
was dismissed after making a joke a
second juror was dismissed last week due
to an issue with her pregnancy
quote written house is on trial for
fatally shooting two men and wounding a
third i think you know for the most part
we know a lot of the details about
rittenhouse and the trial but we'll get
into more of the
the trial details in a second
this is where i think um
this is where kyle could lose so we've
been talking quite a bit about the trial
we've been talking about how for the
past several days uh and the latest news
today is that the prosecution has has
rest uh they they've rested their case
or however the proper terminology is
their case has been rested
and now it's going into the defense the
defense's case in chief they're now
bringing their witnesses
they brought in the state so i know um
you know steve you haven't been
following this but i'll give you some
some context the state brought in richie
mcginnis it was their witness
and he made them look miserable he said
you know this guy was attacking kyle
they brought in another witness who said
one of the guys who got shot threatened
to kill kyle and then they bring in gage
gross kreutz who
testified that it wasn't until he
pointed his gun at kyle rittenhouse that
he got fired upon
after seeing all of that
you know my answer is like wow
my prediction is like he's probably
gonna get acquitted on most of these
charges he might get a misdemeanor gun
charge he might get a manslaughter
charge but all the murder stuff it's all
out the window
then we hear that somebody is filming
the jury
and we know what that leads to
it's it's an amazing story i and
actually just as i'm sitting here
listening to you and and and we were
just talking about it
i'm seeing why it's so interesting
um
and how you've got this situation where
there's a narrative and the narrative
has to be upheld at all costs you know
this is what happens with the media as
we know
and yet the facts just one by one
start to
the crazy way it and when you talk about
the jury i mean that is that's really
scary that that i mean why why is that
even allowed to have i mean what what
the details of that in terms of like
where where they were filmed and
shouldn't they be have the buzz
yeah but the jury's being picked up how
do they know where that is right what's
that about right
so we have this viral video where
they're basically saying we know who the
jury is this guy
sounds like he's saying if the jury
doesn't give them the verdict they want
they're going to target them and we saw
that during the chauvin trial with the
the george floyd cop you know derek
chovin they they were riding in the
streets people had to be brought into
the courtroom with armed police someone
one of the witnesses houses was was
covered in blood like a pig's head or
something but he had moved from there
but they're they're targeting the jury
they should uh with treat targeting
jurors as targeting children
for for legal purposes i'd love to see
people but there must be some hammer
down there must be big i mean when the
judge says oh i'm surprised and what do
you say disappoint i don't know what he
said i'm surprised this happened you
know i mean yeah
to put it mildly i mean isn't that to
your point isn't there a
um isn't this a question
intimidating a jury obstruction of
justice isn't it i don't know anyone
absolutely but else from being a lawyer
there must be something it's interesting
that he's surprised because i'm not if
you're looking at this story online on
social media there's a whole bunch of
people threatening the jury there's a
whole people
threatening that there's going to be
rioting there's going to be huge
protests in response if they don't get
the decision that they want to get in
this specific trial so i mean he
shouldn't be surprised because this is a
high profile case that the world is
watching right now this is this is going
to be significant because you see the
party line split you see the agendas you
see the narratives and people are
playing this off as a part of the larger
political wars that are happening in
this country that are becoming more
dangerous to be played i i think it's
it's sad to see the judge really doesn't
know what's going on
and it's not it's not a judge's job to
watch the news and understand politics
in this country but for him to be like
oh somebody was filming the jury that's
strange it's like yo they these people
were burning down buildings smashing
windows and they were pushing a dumpster
a flaming dumpster into a towards a gas
station and this and this judge doesn't
understand that these are political
experts you don't you don't know that
the the
people doing that with the people
filming
but i mean the the fact is that they
the fact that it was filmed at all by
anyone
is so
like
antithetical to everything that people
think about how the justice system works
should work yeah but these people these
look you know and actually there's a
broader point to your point which is
that the revolution they keep saying
over and over again again going back to
the narrative that you know the right
and the trump you know trump trumpets
and whatever are sort of you know
undermining democracy and threatening
violence and and all this kind of stuff
it's it's the ex it's the exact opposite
on so many occasions and it's
funny
it reminds me of the um do you remember
around the election night when it was
always about um whether when they were
boarding up the cities yeah um
everyone's like boarding up you had
those pictures of new york being boarded
up in in in the event that they would be
rioting on the on election night well
who were they boarding it up against
yeah there's not a lot of trump
supporters in new york it was it's the
same sort of story it's always
it's it's actually the louder they they
push a particular message the more clear
it is that actually is the direct
opposite of what's really going on isn't
it isn't that crazy i mean russiagate
everything that democrats were saying
they were projecting what they had done
on trump and trump supporters when it
comes to the violence all day every day
the media keeps saying the right wing
and the far right and the white
supremacists and it's just like where
when i mean there's been a couple of bad
you know really really bad incidents
with with the fringe far right or
whatever but it's like you get anti for
riots for with a hundred plus days of
them firebombing a federal building and
yet we we now know at the written house
trial the fbi had evidence that these
people committed crimes that the
prosecutor in the written house case
knew
that one of kyle reynolds's attackers
was illegally concealing a weapon
and in the prosecutors instructed the
police not to use to to
execute a search warrant against his
phone i mean the whole thing is crooked
and it's always been crooked and the
scariest part about is that when they
come out and they lie about it or or
more importantly
when the judge doesn't understand he's
like wow i'm surprised someone was
filming our jury it's like
your honor
they will kill the jurors
if they have the opportunity more but
but i will stress that that is
hyperbolic what these people do because
they're smarter than this as much people
don't want to give them credit is they
know
that in order to effectively engage in
terror you can't take life
what what the far left does is sustained
low tier terrorism
smashing windows starting fires beating
people things that won't get national
headlines but will scare people into
bending the knee and giving in to their
politics so when antifa can go out for
100 plus days in portland smashing
windows and beating people
is guy gets punched in face a national
headline no
so antifa and these father extremists
know they can go out punch random people
those people will then become scared to
say anything because no one will tell
their story and the police won't do
anything about it
then antifa is emboldened and the far
left just keep doing more and more stuff
like this so yeah what the purpose of
filming the jury
isn't actually to cause them harm it's
to cause the fear of the fear no it's a
total intimidation tactic
but it's incredibly
scary that that's that that's actually i
mean
that's going on and
it sounds like nothing's going to happen
no no and the judge was like oh i told
him delete it and it's like so they
still have the footage i'll say i'll say
one thing i'll throw two before i throw
to you luke the uh the fear
of pain
is actually more powerful in a tor in
torture than the pain itself so you'll
read this about like the cia torturing
people they know
putting the fear that pain is coming is
more likely to get your results than
actually
in you know inflicting pain on someone
when someone's feeling the pain they
actually like okay i can endure this
before they receive it so filming the
jury is basically the threat they want
these people to be living in fear so
that they just say i don't want to stick
my neck out for this guilty guilty
guilty there was also many instances
where the authorities stood down when
there was widespread criminality looting
burning robbing people assaulting people
police officers literally standing down
sometimes even seeing the incidences not
doing anything during this hot summer
that we had of course last year during
all the rioting and you know you know
there was even instances where people's
civil rights were violated because
someone had a different opinion police
officers said well there's a mob here
they're rioting we have to violate your
civil rights because we don't feel like
dealing with any problems with any
issues and we would like to think that
public opinion doesn't sway juries
doesn't sway court proceedings it does
as much as money does because here in
the united states if you have a lot of
money if you have also the public
opinion if you have all the institutions
behind you you could buy a lot of
justice and the police will always err
on the side of
whatever's easier
so i i said this years ago and i i
warned all these you know these these
back the blue conservatives
if black lives matter or antifa shows up
to your house the cop is going to look
at the mob
look at you and say it's easier to to
arrest you in your own home than it is
to deal with a violent mob or a riot and
we've actually seen that there was a guy
in wisconsin black lives matter shows up
to his house the same group had
previously set fire to another house and
they're protesting
the police end up showing up so this guy
in his window brandishes a shotgun at
the crowd
the police show up and arrest him to
cheers of black lives matter antifa
which is funny because they're the
defund the police crowd but when the
police are coming and serving them and
arresting a guy in his own home
because they were protesting him
they cheer for it that's that's the
power they want so i people need to
realize this the cops will absolutely
with a smile on their face kick you in
the teeth if it means well i totally
agree it's so funny you say that because
i remember when when in in in the
beginning of the pandemic and you had
cops going around you know arresting
people and being unbelievably aggressive
towards like moms with their kids in the
playground whatever all that stuff i say
well actually you know we ever this is
just all of this kind of behavior this
kind of authoritarian behavior in any
direction this is going to undermine
confidence
um in the police and we all you know you
want order you want the police please
that you want everyone to have
confidence in it and when you go around
behaving like that
um when you're not doing the central job
which is to uphold the law equally with
the same kind of
approach to everyone people decide to
lose confidence and then you just
everything starts to fall apart it's
actually a real disaster it's just about
what's easier yeah can can two cops who
pull up in a squad car deal with 50
angry people throwing stones
no but can they arrest you yes and then
there's nothing to protest anymore we
saw you on this can i just ask on the
jury thing like did would they know
that just on the extent of the
intimidation
would they be aware that this happened i
mean mate would i don't think seeing the
person would they have seen this story
you know how's it all played out so
they're not so the jury is instructed
not to read news about the case not to
discuss it with anyone and for the most
part that typically works they're not
sequestered
but there you are getting onto a bus and
someone walks up filming you and you
know exactly what that means because the
jurors know that their identities are
kept anonymous they know why their
identities are kept secret
so when someone films you you know it's
no longer a secret no matter what the
the judge says and these people like
like you know we mentioned in the story
a lot of these people know the full
weight of what's going on with with the
written house trial and they have strong
feelings about it
so i think the jury is now so you never
see the jury on we were talking about
this it's all along the trials being you
can watch the transfer you never see the
jury never know you don't want any jury
intimidation yeah these people are
deciding the faith of kyle and if some
of them are intimidated or harassed or
extorted or even bought off
or even you know threatened
you have you know a legal system that of
course it's actually a really shocking
story i mean you know
like thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time